from a character inspired by action star
Steven Seagal to gourmet dishes
handcrafted by an award-winning Chef The
Untold Truth of the menu is chock full
of tasty tidbits
the menu is a very tightly wound film
with a lot of precision but that doesn't
mean there wasn't room for improvisation
on set Stars Anya Taylor joy and
Nicholas Holt revealed that they had
plenty of time to improvise together
while filming in a video segment for
Vanity Fair Taylor Joy explained that
director Mark mylad wanted all the
actors to be improvising while the
camera was on other characters and they
were sitting in the background Taylor
Joy revealed so we we committed to The
Improv like pretty hardcore the first
couple of days Taylor Joy also confessed
that she improvised a line during a
scene with Rafe finds and was terrified
afterwards during the scene in question
Taylor Joy's character Margot primly
tells Fine's character Chef slowik thank
you as he's leaving their table and it's
clearly a passive aggressive move on her
part Taylor Joy recalls adding the line
and thinking very fines is going to
think I'm an absolute Bratz because that
was not script my Lord kept her ad-lib
in the film and she felt Vindicated as a
result
John Leguizamo plays Georgie Diaz a
washed up action star whose pompous and
arrogant he's clearly past his prime but
still behaves as if he's on top of the
world as it turns out Leguizamo based
his performance on a real actor former
co-star Steven Seagal if I find out July
and we'll come back and kill you in your
own kitchen Leguizamo told the ultimate
rabbit I modeled after Steven Seagal
because I did a movie with him and in
rehearsals he knocked me out and he
didn't care as The Story Goes Segal
shoved Leguizamo against a wall after
losing his temper Leguizamo brought up
the fact that he used Seagal as his
inspiration for the menu in another
interview with Entertainment Weekly
confirming that the film they clashed on
was 1996's executive decision one of
Segal's better rated movies Leguizamo
told the outlet I had a bad run-in with
him he's kind of a horrible human
one of the central tensions in the menu
is the fact that Margot doesn't want to
eat the food chef slow wake has so
painstakingly prepared for her Tyler on
the other hand who's played by Nicholas
Holt is in his element what this meant
for Anya Taylor Joy was that she didn't
have to spend much of the film eating
unlike Colt Taylor Joy discussed how
impressed she was with Holt's eating
abilities during an interview with BBC
Radio 1 revealing that he attacked every
take with so much Gusto and fervor and
somehow managed to keep it all down Holt
told Vanity Fair that the hardest day on
set was when he gorged himself on bread
a day that Taylor Joy described as bread
gate
if the high dining experience shown in
the menu feels very real that's because
a real-life Superstar Chef was a
consultant on the film French chef
Dominique cran the only woman in the U.S
with a three Michelin star restaurant
worked to make the menu described in the
script a reality kren crafted many of
the dishes herself often redoing them
several times when scenes required
numerous takes according to the
Hollywood Reporter one dish which
features a scallop balanced atop a rock
is a near replica of a dish at crenzone
restaurant San Francisco's Atelier kren
kren told The Hollywood Reporter every
dish was created in a way that the actor
could feel and eat with emotion she also
spoke with Rafe fines about the
psychological aspects of his character
describing how mentally exhausting it is
to be the head of a restaurant of that
stature does kren see herself as a mad
Genius Like Chef slow Wick the chef told
Bon Appetit I'm not as crazy as he is
but I understand his way of thinking
Nicholas Holtz Tyler is the resident
Foodie in the menu he's not a chef
himself but he's obsessed with the world
of food as such Tyler has obviously
watched every episode of the Netflix
docu-series Chef's Table something he
proudly admits to if you've watched
Chef's Table yourself you might have
noticed some similarities between how
that series and the menu were shot these
similarities were intentional chef's
table creator David Gelb was actually
hired as a second unit director on the
film reports the New York Times gelb's
entire purpose for being on set was to
film the restaurant and the staff in
exactly the same way an episode of
Chef's Table would be shot fans of the
series will likely recognize the slow
motion close-ups and the focus on small
details the bright heat of a blue flame
the Precision of a hand laying down a
tiny piece of food on a plate the film's
climax is also a reference to Chef's
Table director Mike mylad told The
Hollywood Reporter that the final
s'mores dish was an homage to a dessert
made by Grant acketts at his restaurant
in Chicago which was featured in an
episode of Chef's Table akit's dessert
is laid out over the entire table which
my lot expanded to Encompass the entire
restaurant the aerial shot of the
s'mores dish is a tribute to that
specific dessert but also to the
cinematography of chef's table as a
whole
the menu is quite a mysterious film in
which the backgrounds of some characters
are left in the dark that's especially
true of Elsa the austere Hostess
character played by Hong Chao speaking
with Awards radar Chao describes the
process of deepening the character of
Elsa which involved a lot of
conversations with director Mike mylad
she explained that she was shooting a
movie in Portland Oregon when she got
the role and she wanted to bring some of
the city's funkiness to the character
ciao had her own ideas about how Elsa
should look though Milad wasn't
especially receptive to them at least at
first Chao told Awards radar Mike milod
and the writers were imagining that Elsa
would be very plain and not stand out
that her clothes would sort of lack any
personality luckily Chao found an ally
in Amy Wescott the film's costume
designer and also the director's wife
Amy Wescott was very willing to conspire
with me against Mike mylad Chowan on to
explain to the outlet the outfit they
ended up with a sort of modern Victorian
look is unique enough to give Elsa some
personality but not too zany that it
contradicts the serious atmosphere at
the restaurant the menu was written by
Seth Reese and will Tracy two comedians
who have plenty of experience in satire
Reese spent several years at Late Night
with Seth Meyers and Tracy worked on
succession and both screenwriters
previously worked for the onion of all
their career experiences it was their
time at the satirical News website that
proved to be most influential in the
making of the menu Reese told slash film
this is a very ununy type of movie in
terms of how specific the world is that
we're creating the language that goes
into that and then also how sad everyone
is
Judith Light is a veteran Hollywood
actor known for her vast body of work on
television and film and on Broadway she
has a small but important part in the
menu that of Anne a wealthy woman who
frequents the restaurant with her
husband but doesn't seem to enjoy the
food all that much speaking with Cinema
Daily Light explained that she's a
foodie herself something that Drew her
to the role light told the outlet I'm a
cook my husband's a cook we had a
restaurant in Aspen Colorado I'm
fascinated by that by the chemistry of
cooking by the joy of giving to other
people and that's always been a big
thing for me light went on to say that
she grew up in a family of female Cooks
which is why it was such a pleasure to
see the famous French chef Dominique
kren in action during the shoot the
actor told Cinema daily the experience
of her is watching a great artist
there's a kind of beauty and simplicity
and centeredness and a very Zen quality
that she carries within her where she is
the creation
certain roles require actors to do
intense prep work whether it be learning
a new skill perfecting an accent or
transforming their bodies for the stars
of the menu preparation for the film was
far more enjoyable speaking with The
Hollywood Reporter Anya Taylor Joy joked
this was a very hard job in terms of
research both Nick and I spent a lot of
time on the couch watching a chef's
table it was really hard Nicholas Holtz
Tyler is obsessed with shows like chef's
table so binge watching the series was
always going to be helpful for him
however he didn't stop there Taylor Joy
also revealed that Holt went even
further in his research actually going
out to eat at some of these fine dining
restaurants himself Holt joked they went
nice food because I had to Anya Taylor
joy and Nicholas Holt have shared that
they did a lot of improvising while
their characters were sitting in the
background but there was one moment of
improvisation that was front and center
near the end of the film Chef slow Wick
reveals to Margot the extent of Tyler's
deception he had known all along how the
night would end and invited Margot
anyway when Margot hears this she slaps
Tyler across the face as Nicholas Holtz
told BBC Radio one Tyler definitely
deserved a slap in the face but that
moment wasn't actually in the script
Anya Taylor Joy explained her decision
saying I have a thing about feminine
rage she went on to reveal that she
often gets scripts that have men doing
terrible things to women and the women
just sitting there and absorbing those
Terrible Things upset but not angry
after reading the big reveal moment in
the script Taylor Joy went up to
director Mark mylad and told him I'm
really sorry but the only way to play
this truthfully is for me to like attack
him my Lord eventually came around to
Taylor Joy's way of thinking and she got
to react to Tyler's betrayal
authentically how did Holt feel about
the slap the actor joked and I didn't
like it
Chef slow Wick's menu for the evening
was meticulously planned out which is
part of the reason why he doesn't take
too kindly to the unexpected appearance
of Margot to make matters worse Margot
is entirely unreceptive to his brand of
culinary genius and refuses to play
along as one of his dutiful awestruck
guests most of margot's stubbornness is
in the script of course but Anya Taylor
Joy made a character choice on set that
made her dislike of him even more
explicit unfortunately she put herself
in a bit of pain in doing so she told
BBC Radio 1 that she thought it was
important that Margot have her back to
the chef in order to illustrate how she
really feels about him what this meant
in practice was that Taylor Joy had to
be constantly twisting around to look at
Chef slow Wick while he delivered his
monologues about the food she told the
outlet that essentially meant three
months of like the worst neck pain you
could ever possibly imagine Taylor Joy
expanded on the experience further in a
video segment for Vanity Fair noting
that despite the back problems it gave
her I still maintained it was a good
choice
[Music]